i'm going to tell you something i
shouldn't
something you are not going to believe
[Music]
six months ago it started falling
and there is more coming what happened
here we sucked her through 14 stories
we work for a division of the government
that investigates scientific anomalies
we found another one and you're not
gonna believe this she's defying
gravity
that's new there was this piece
in missouri evaporated a lake and this
one's roughly the same size but it's
twice as powerful
what is it i think it's some sort of
portal
it's encircling the town
[Music]
why do you do this i want to be sure the
good guys get this technology before
anyone else
stop we have to find a way to save their
lives
there's a way i know the debris is here
for a reason
i feel it connecting us and no matter
why
it's here it's going to change us all
our greatest weapon against darkness
isn't our superpowers
it's our humanity and our love for each
other
i know this is right i have faith son
we will get iris back oh god i'm still
here
this enemy is all powerful it's not just
mirrors she's manipulating
it's any reflective surface requesting
backup
i called in a little bit of extra muscle
anyone can save the world with their
might
it takes a real hero to do it with his
heart i know how to open a portal to the
mirror verse
i'll never stop fighting to reach you
what are you
the product of your broken mind
give me back my wife then you have one
percent of your speed left let's make it
count
[Applause]
run
the only way to keep a secret between
two people is to kill one of them
it's kind of true
the state of utah has long been the home
of the mormons
i love the gospel with all my heart
they are driven by history and they want
to preserve
documents
mark hoffman found document after
document
first editions history americana worth
1.5 million dollars
he was rock star
[Applause]
religion sometimes breeds amongst people
some extremes
the first explosion ripped through a
downtown office building
killing one man the second explosion
outside of a holiday home
claimed another life panic began to
ensue because
two bombs suggest a serial killer then
the shock came there
are very expensive documents in the
automobile
this is an original yes this is an
original copy the salamander letter gave
a far different story of the church's
roots instead of god and angels now it's
salamanders and magic
best material was potentially
devastating
people who wanted to protect the church
didn't want this document to come to
life
as a speculation the church was trying
to acquire it in order to suppress it
everyone's a suspect what do you think
about lying for the lord
it just started snowballing machine guns
bombs we all should have suspected
secrets just can't be kept
[Music]
you ever heard of john rusty is this a
joke who hasn't heard of me
you're about to meet the greatest
american author that ever lived
he was murdered last night mr rothstein
i'm a huge fan i've been waiting for
this moment my
entire life john rothstein the eccentric
and enigmatic author was found dead
monday
they're saying that what i did was worse
than the mr mercedes guy
you got the manuscripts
no what
case number six two three two four
people love ohio versus lube link later
asking 12
jurors to condemn the woman who saved
the world from
mr mercedes you gotta get me out of here
he finds me in here
who finds you brady are you all right
let's link later
she talks to brady and he answers back
some kid came into the bookstore asking
about rothstein
the insurance company they've offered a
reward seven hundred thousand dollars
that means we're no longer doing this
just for the love of literature we're
talking money
there's somebody looking for those books
somebody who will kill to get them
we need to turn the screws on this kit
now
i count the biggest monster in the
history of this town the public is going
to set me free
we're running out of time he's got
something we want we need to get
something he wants is
[Music]
remember i said after brady hartsfield
there'd never be another
there's another
[Music]
never thought we'd come back here after
after we barely escaped with our lives
all i know is we're going to get the
hell out of here
could really use your help
[Music]
somebody anybody
we hit from the world for five years
this is not living
we're just waiting here to die we're
waiting for mom and dad they're never
coming back guys
help isn't coming
[Music]
why did you enter this facility through
the roof shortcut
and why did you not use the ladder
shorter cut
we have a fighting chance to find mom
and dad
it's like the world's gone crazy small
kaiju
him i don't know what's necessary or
right
listen to me we'll show them what we can
do
i advise immediate retreat wrong advice
together we keep going
i'll return to fight and if we're
walking
we'll survive the day
go go go
[Music]
what is that
[Music]
paradise is totally destroyed at least
we were able to survive the blast
who's a fart only put one day's worth of
food in the bomb shelter
look i'm like a flying squirrel
our town is a radioactive wasteland
things are getting strange around here
what's wrong with my face karen's
pregnant
randall look hey what are you doing with
my stuff i'm baby proofing oh this is
dangerous
how are my billiard balls danger
gina you can't do that here i'll relax
i'm just looking for my keys
to my masturbation hut
please don't look at me i'm hideous get
in here you beautiful bastard
can you take that away from him
[Music]
i think i'm falling for kevin kevin
kevin
um damn it kevin this is my fantasy
secrets not yours
hey i'm a bong with tits bullet
well where are you going you can't fit
in there you can't fit in there
[Music]
yeah we getting weird this season
[Music]
easy he's the only one who sees the big
picture
sees the future this plan
if this fails
our brothers are going to be gunning for
you
i've never been afraid of swing
god help us all
[Music]
we
out in the dark
among the stars
[Music]
the god is dead
[Applause]
i had a dream
almost like a premonition
i think there's an attack coming
this wall will fall
[Music]
i need warriors i'm building an alliance
to defend ourselves
how do you know your team's strong
enough if you can't bring down the
charging bull
then don't wave the red cape at it
[Music]
you're sitting here for a reason
and even if it takes you the rest of
your life
find out what that reason is
[Applause]
they said the age of heroes would never
come again
it will it has to
[Music]
we live in a society where honor
is a distant memory isn't that right
batman
so who would like to start
mr barnes why does sam aggravate you
15 seconds to drop so what's our plan
great
[Music]
superheroes cannot be allowed
to exist
[Music]
i have no intention to leave my work
unfinished
[Music]
the wall's upside down right now
oh yeah what is it is you ready
here we go again huh
hello girl kick your ass
[Music]
see that wasn't so hard are you ready
is you ready
just blank sweet jesus i mean how old
are you
[Music]
hasn't started yet oh god not dancing or
nice
quick it's starting i might want you
later
i think i might be too old for that sort
of stuff we're never going to be the
wilton
i don't need us to be the walton's home
i'd like to do with the monsters at this
point or the manson family at least they
had a shared interest
i think anger is healthy don't you dare
talk to me like that
you defined us willfully and
deliberately no birthday
at all counseling a child's birthday are
you in a roald dahl book
sometimes i have to be a good cop i just
like to can't get to sleep
my heart is beating so fast i could be
one of the minds now that's drive me
slightly mad that we can't just make
them do what we want anymore
i believe in god i want people to know
i'm a vegan
i'm already shoveling that in i wanted
to support you
i've got one vegan kid and one religious
kid i like the kardashians
sometimes it's all just so intense
thanks we're all supposed to pretend
like we cope so well but we're all over
screaming inside can you please just
give me a [ __ ] moment
oh vaginal dryness
leon's mom told me you were smoking in
their gazebo what's a gazebo i don't
[ __ ] know
you should eat something eating makes
you fat die being fat isn't terrible
since when were we the kind of family
that retreats into separate rooms to
look at separate screens
[Music]
we're actually making some progress
hello i'm just decanting a shiraz
[Music]
this is the first time you're speaking
publicly
i had no need to talk to the media
they were looking for sensationalism and
they were looking for the monster
police found 29 bodies buried under
gacy's suburban chicago homes a very
good neighbor
we socialize with them
gacy was well respected in his community
and even dressed up as a clown to
entertain children
he said to me clouds can get away with
murder
in disguise
gacy was convicted of murdering more
people than anyone else in u.s history
the dead won't bother you it's the
living you got to worry about
[Music]
there were red flags all along the way
that for some reason nobody paid
attention to
we're learning so much now we would
never have known at the time
could gacy have done this alone maybe
there's a cover up here
mom protected john she carried secrets
she went to the grave with
the thing everybody thought they knew
wasn't the whole story
the ship is totally repaired we can
finally leave this [ __ ] planet
so long earth suckers enjoy the melting
ice caps
no no no no no no no no no no no
it hey we're still trapped on earth this
puts us right back to where we were a
year ago oh my god make a bigger deal
about it
i'm just glad everything is back to
normal yo dork
are you crazy where are your masks i
didn't know we needed masks i've been
breathing here for over a year
let's get the hell out of here quick
grab a scooter
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that it's called big
dick energy and when i get it i'll be
unstoppable
i don't know a big dick seems really
dangerous
run everyone rod i can't control it
the slurpee and distress call we have to
help them looks like the solar opposites
are going to london what could go wrong
suck my butt officer [ __ ]
the solar opposites are going to jail
he doesn't have a hole we'll just have
to make one okay
how are we still so bad at this i don't
want to point fingers at the weak link
here but get your [ __ ] together
[Music]
this is gonna be awesome we're in the
big city you can be anything you want
out here superhero politician
orthodontist
a prostitute you wanna have some fun
sugar
no [ __ ] way
release your unholy creation are these
from brooklyn
[Music]
we're turning people into wines these
people love wine look how happy they are
on the labels
[Music]
knock it off todd i think amber's been
pretty clear about how she feels
i'm nothing like my dad i want to be
just like you
i fought to keep this planet safe
your power's got to be due any day now
son
morning i'm scared dad what if i can't
do this
follow me go down
land i said land stop
get up i'm actually getting used to this
a little that's not good
i need to be better after everything
he's done how can i live up to all that
you need to decide what kind of hero you
want to be
that was you in the blue and the yellow
why don't you meet the team after school
may we count on you in the future
yeah i think so and bored of this
son we need to talk
what i'm about to tell you will change
everything
dad
i wasn't ready before now i am
you being a superhero is the coolest
thing that's ever happened to me now
take me flying or i'm gonna tell
everyone you're invincible sorry not
[Music]
sorry
a darkness has come to london
something moves through the streets
like the shadow of a nightmare
it eviscerates all who stand against it
now all hope rests with these
unlikely few if they fail
there will be more terror there will be
more
death
you think you've seen horror
you know nothing of what it is to be
[Music]
afraid
you